we want to start today's episode and
just let everybody on on New Zealand we
have a lot of listeners they're
beautiful listeners that reach out all
the time and just let them know that you
know our hearts are with them and I know
it's just uh you know you just I'm sorry
that this sort of thing is there this
sort of travesty and and that it's
anywhere but just wanted to let you know
that we were thinking of you happy st.
Patty's Day to everybody so if you got a
small buddy or whatever or even just
somebody who's a loves alcohol or just
likes green lipstick or anything
you know if you like somebody you know a
lot of people smoke crack on st.
Patrick's Day and it has nothing to do
with being Irish or anything or nothing
about luck so whatever what I'm saying
is this today's episode is brought to
you by grey block pizza grey block if
you've have not yet had the experience
of something in your mouth that has
cheese and meat and sauce on it then you
can have that at grey block pizza 18:11
Pico Boulevard in Los Angeles on the way
to the beach gray block get that hitter
also announcing some new tour dates
right now in Australia will be adding
May 22nd at the end more theater May
24th I'll be at Gold Fields in Melbourne
May 25th
I'll be at the Metro Theatre in Sydney
May 26th I'll be at the a store Theatre
in Perth May 29th at a East AEC Theatre
in Adelaide May 31st the plenary one in
Melbourne and that June 1st is BCE Sea
Grant Hall in Brisbane one or two of
those may have added a late show as well
I would just go check all of those out
the Oh Vaughn calm / tour tou are also
support for this past weekend comes from
manscaped who is number one in men's
below the belt grooming that's right
men's below the belt grooming manscaped
offers precision-engineered tools for
manscaping with the right tool for the
right job
now we all have had times like for me
I'll be running late for a wedding or
you know would do a rollerskating meetup
or something and I'll just quickly
decide oh right now is when you know get
out the shower and I'll see my crotch
area and I'll see you know it looks like
it looks like if you know an old lady's
yard after her husband passes away or
something you're like damn somebody
needs to get over there what a whacker
you know they got you know vines
everywhere and just [ __ ] you know run
amok and so that's when I'll get down
get some scissors real quick and I'll
try to tidy up sometimes I'll get a
lighter and even just run it just light
it and bend over and just really quickly
just flash it back and forth around my
nuts and bottom to get those long reach
your hair's well manscaped doesn't want
us doing that type of stuff anymore
it's the perfect package 2.0 kit
features the lawn mower 2.0 with
skin-safe technology this trimmer won't
Knick or snag your nuts that's what it
says with an exclamation point at the
end it's also 100% waterproof and shock
resistant wu precision tools for your
family jewels your balls will thank you
you can get 20% off free shipping and a
free travel bag with the code th EO at
manscaped comm ma n s CA PE d dot-com
that's 20% off with free shipping and a
free travel bag at manscaped calm and
use code Theo
take care of yourself get your crotch a
practical cut man escapes ends a
beautiful box they got the tremor they
got the mower they got that hitter you
feel I mean you feel [ __ ] you know I
mean Guatemalan after that I mean your
nuts feel like they could dance you know
you feel like you're ready for something
new you could take your nuts back to
kindergarten that's how young and fresh
and ample they look so take care of your
body okay let's start off with remember
this original old theme song we had for
this past weekend some of you new
listeners may not even know it
oh yeah
[Music]
celebrate ms
celebrate
celebrate all your pain and that is the
Spencer Jacob growl band and that's
growl not like growl like an animal does
but growl like you're almost angry GRA
you and that's their song celebrate and
Spencer lent us that song a long time
ago to kick off the episodes and I saw
him the other night at the Comedy Store
and it was awesome he had a new little
dime piece with him you know and she was
a tall dime to I mean she was you know
two nickels stacked on each other I mean
she was hightly lady and and they really
looked like they were having just a
blast so it's nice to see him and nice
to have the song again happy st.
Patrick's Day it's that time I'm in
studio and our producer Nick Davis is
here with me today what's going on Theo
not much man how was your weekend it was
good it was good pretty pretty relaxed
I'm all fired up I've been listening a
lot Jaco willing lately really yeah yeah
he's a prioritizing execute oh yeah I've
got a lot of the play so I just trying
to knock it out and how's he doing is he
sound like he's doing okay I'm Way back
in the catalogue so who knows he could
be dead by now when it once I get to the
current episodes but yeah episodes 1
through 10 amazing Wow ok so his early
so yeah so his early stuff is poppin
yeah yeah I'm a jackal willing hipster I
only listen to his early stuff oh yeah I
love that in Jaco willing cos a Navy
SEAL that you know um led a lot of
charges there in Iraq and Afghanistan
and has done a lot of stuff in the
Middle East and just a real I mean he
definitely wears the pants in his family
I would say that he's that kind of man
did you do anything for st. Patty's Day
uh no I listened to a bunch of
voicemails uh did some work I watched
the UFC fights mm-hmm that work but
today's st. Patty's Day so I'm hanging
out with you nice yeah happy st. Patty's
dude I was thinking about this man they
don't have you know st. Patty's is one
of those you know holidays a lot of
times and I'll say holiday
they also often sensationalize little
people and some people say midgets if
you're you know 60 year older you say
[ __ ] and if you're you know 40 or
younger you say little people and if
you're 40 to 60 you say whatever you
want and then somebody either correct
you or they don't but you know you do
notice that like a lot of holidays it's
like you know the they got the little
guy on st. Patrick's Day or the little
lady's Santa has the elves you know on
Halloween they may have a little
Frankenstein or you know a little bloody
Benny you know or a little vampire guy
when you have a little fella just
dripping blood off of his face do you
notice that yeah definitely and then
when it's not a holiday they're making
cookies yeah I don't know oh yeah that's
true a lot of those channels a
sensationalism they say oh let's see
these little arms make a cake or let's
see these you know little legs run to
get a fresh egg and some of that [ __ ]
man it's like you know it had me
thinking the other day I was thinking
about somebody had a fancy like this
beautiful little poodle named waffle you
know and it was like a little toy poodle
they said and it was I mean this [ __ ]
thing was probably eight inches square
you know like I mean in his fluffy I
mean it seemed like something you'd see
it Restoration Hardware
you know just perched on you know a
little fake deal and um and I was like
that's kind of crazy they had they were
because they you what they do is they
get little they get dogs small dogs to
do sex and then make a little dog and
then they keep doing it it's [ __ ]
crazy man imagine if you did that with
little people I was thinking what if you
had you know you have a party you invite
you know you know little Janet and
[ __ ] small [ __ ] you know small
Andy over and then you get them all you
know you know slip them each a roofie or
something get them to [ __ ] in the back
room right unbeknownst to them just so
they make a smaller child and then you
know when that kid gets old enough to
have sex and as you know knows a female
if it's a male that wants to have sex
then you get them to come over I mean in
[ __ ] in 60 years you could have a
person that
in this bag you know you can have a guy
who just runs around in your desk and
get you a pin if you need it you know
like you could have anything but it just
seems like because for all the Fiasco's
you hear about the dog community we got
to support this community and you know
dogs Without Borders and you know no
more whistles and all of this [ __ ] it's
like at the same time there's this other
darker universe where they're you know
down breeding these animals to make them
as small as possible
mm-hmm it's it's kind of horrific
actually yeah well it's just if you did
it with your friends or something if you
did it with small people it would be I
think it would be frowned upon did a
hundred percent honey you know let's go
drink with a bunch of little people and
get them all to [ __ ] again so they can
keep making smaller little people you
know you could have a [ __ ] you know I'm
just a hint it and and two hundred years
you could have a [ __ ] little
four-inch girl in your pocket you know
in there this [ __ ] counting change
just organized you know moving quarters
over here and nickels over to this side
so anyway I don't know what I was
thinking about that I think just the
holidays and in st. Patrick's Day I was
thinking about this man I was I was
watching some of the videos of the this
past Atlantic City and you helped put
some of that together Nick and no you
did a great job and and I was thinking
when I hit the stage man one thing I was
like I didn't really think that I
thanked the crowd enough I felt like I
had this feel like we did it you know
like that was a feeling that I had that
I wish I maybe had expressed more
because you it's just like yes like
there's just so many people you know and
so many people are excited and it feels
like a group thing I kind of think the
way you think them is by making them
laugh right you held up your end of the
bargain they showed up
you made them laugh it everybody's
grateful right yeah maybe that's it
maybe sometimes I just think I don't
know sometimes I just it's like I always
find like a problem with stuff you know
I don't know what that is but but yeah I
just want to say thank you again
everybody that came out over there and
and we did it man
we really really did it and I it's not
something that I do alone I don't feel
like it's something that we do together
that Nick does that Nick helps out with
and you know in just this whole you know
we got this sweet kind of community
going on and so we got to find some cool
stuff to do we got to get a van bro you
know yeah I love the community it was
really fun listening all those calls
that came in this week oh yeah hearing
other people listening yeah they're
everywhere and they're doing everything
awesome well I'm excited to be there
dude I just went to a NASCAR today
that's sick dude I was in I went took
the casino last night with Megan you
know that does the finances right so we
went to the casino and then we went to
the NASCAR you guys are gambling all the
finances no this is definitely is not a
personal account okay good and uh and
dude I've never been to a NASCAR race
bro you get in there and like it was so
much more chill than I thought it was
gonna be like there's definitely a lot
of people who have had a lot of Mountain
Dew you know like a lot of real people
that know their way around a [ __ ] you
know 1/2 cup of Code Red you know but
you get in there and uh and it's just
awesome it's just like you're getting
some sunshine there were the mountains
in the back it was that auto um it was
at Auto Club Speedway in Fontana and
then you just got you know like Joey
Logano and you know somebody Busch the
third and frickin Larry Truex Jr and
they're just driving around as fast as
they can I can only think of the 90s
guys I know Jeff Gordon yeah and jr.
yeah and that's about it
yeah yeah that's what I was like I kept
asking other people it seems like it's
this guy in it is this guy in it you
just got to pick a deep cut he's your
favorite yeah I picked a couple cars one
car um the the group that I went with
they had their their their company has
sponsored a car and their car was like
dead [ __ ] laughs brah and they were
[ __ ] I was like this edit do you guys
get an uber driver like that guy looks
[ __ ] lost like you definitely look
like he was asking for directions like
all the time like like he just
accidentally got off on the wrong exit
you know and they had one black driver
and the cops pulled him over like on the
second line [ __ ] so racist bro
unbelievable maybe they should get an
uber driver for the cars like a nice
Armenian guy I think he could come in
first oh that would be good huh yeah oh
those guys are if you get one from LA
you know me I'm all about that over life
oh yeah yeah get a nice four point nine
five what is your passenger rating on
uber do you have it yeah it's four point
nine one oh god that's great
yeah I'm I drove for uber for six months
like really really full-time so I feel
like I it's like people who worked in
the service industry they have a ton of
empathy so I'm just always reading the
vibe if they want to talk to they now
want to talk I'm a chuckhole writer yeah
and what's like the worst passenger like
type of passenger to get when you were
driving
I mean drunks really
yeah totally uh had people throw up in
my car I had these two angry lesbians
one time they wanted to go through the
drive-thru and then I refused cuz it was
like it used to be surge pricing at bar
time mhm
and that's when you made all your money
and they want to go right at 2:00 a.m.
and I was like I can't do it and they
they freaked out and they stole all my
waters I have bottles of water oh and
they they grabbed a handful of it and
they smashed my mirror on the way out it
was harrowing really yeah and so the and
that was was that the most violent
incident you had yeah that was
definitely the most violent but one time
I had to help help these girls carry it
carry it just a drunk passed out girl
and I was like do you even know where I
didn't know what I was doing yeah yeah
it's crazy out there it's tough out
there huh and what's the worst type of
driver to get as a passenger do you find
someone who smoked cigarettes honestly
straight up I hate getting in a car that
smells like smoke and you can I love
looking at a drivers rating and like
guessing what type of vehicle I'm gonna
get into there's if they have a little
rating lots of times it's an it's an
odor problem oh really yeah though you
know what I've noticed that too
especially some of them they got a girl
up there a fellow up there and they have
all these snacks you know they got a
couple bags of snacks under the seat
like a couple burgers or something like
that one dude he kept doing gas right
and then he in the door he had one of
those uh Glade just air fresheners he
would fart and then just shoot it like
it was like like it was totally normal
bra he would just blast and then pick it
up and just put a little in the air you
know and to be honest there's not
and worse than I'd rather sit in the gas
I think the combination although that
doesn't really mask it and they just
blend oh yeah
dan that's so dirty huh can't somebody
make a frickin Glade that yeah the
[ __ ] actually helps yeah it smells
like you're a Tom it smells like you're
in a garden where people are growing
[ __ ] also you know like they got the
flowers but then they got the plug-in
[ __ ] shrubs right under them yeah that's
crazy man
can't believe they have that dude
speaking of smoking I want to say this
in three weeks in the past three weeks I
have had three cigarettes and I feels so
much better man congratulations man
thanks ma'am yeah I feel so dude I feel
so much like it's just like a less
stress but in some ways I feel a little
bit more anger because it's like instead
of like being able to go chill out and
have a cigarette I have to like deal
with whatever feeling I'm having so it's
like I have to like you know I have to
figure out why I feel bad instead of
just go have a cigarette to calm me down
mm-hmm but yeah it's been and that's
been doing the chantix people you know I
got a lot of messages said Thea don't do
the chantix it'll kill you you know my
cousin jumped off a bridge my cousin
jumped into a [ __ ] volcano somebody
said I'm like what dude that's your
cousin bro you don't say like that eh if
I can change it can't blame ray liotta
for that yeah it doesn't say it doesn't
say on the package like you know stay
out of a Wahoo but yeah I'm feeling
better man and so it's worked for me I'm
not working for the company rethink that
but I am Telling You that chanak's has
worked for me I'm grateful that we got a
lot of people last week we just wanted
to know who listens to the podcast and
we got a lot of calls that came in and
so I want to hit a couple of those right
now listen and my name is Kevin and I'm
a Jimmy John's driver ooh Kevin my
favorite sandwiches and you know I'll
[ __ ] take a turkey ton of the face
any time
I mean dude if somebody had a bazooka
and they walked up to me and had a
turkey time in it and fired that [ __ ]
as fast as they could right into my
mouth I would take a chance at it
those t-shirt cannons with Jimmy John
yeah our way whether that man they got
that you know um and I like watching
black girls eat Jimmy John's dude I
remember when I be in Louisiana
sometimes they had these two black girls
that live by me uh and they [ __ ] get
a Jimmy John footlong split that thing
god damn man that [ __ ] would make my
butt wet you know it just made me feel
different so I missed some of that
onward brother thanks for calling Kevin
in Milwaukee and yep I know you like
them Jimmy John the median hit it gang
boy and they are beautiful dude some
people [ __ ] with the tuna dude I ain't
getting fish at a [ __ ] sandwich shop
bro say that's that save that water
cattle for the ocean bro you know I'll
get fish if I'm taking a lady out if I'm
proposing to a woman I'll buy a cut of
fish mine ain't [ __ ] around just
getting [ __ ] fish all half-heartedly
have one at 1:00 a.m. in the morning we
don't even know anybody in the building
and they doing it with a ice-cream scoop
or get the [ __ ] out of here I got way
more respect for fish then I'll let
somebody serve me part of their dead
body out of a [ __ ] ice cream scoop
and you should not you Kevin you sound
like a nice guy
let's hear more calling us you know when
I'm cruising around delivering these
shows you know these hearts alarms you
know roast beef oh yeah all I'm very
cows when I do all of it brah nobody
delivers dead animals like my boys
[ __ ] keV over there I'm Mill walk I'm
listening this past weekend and I'll be
honest man sometimes I kind of cheat on
you and with the new bilberries podcast
as well but this past weekend bumping in
this Honda on the court all day Gang
Gang boy Honda Accord and my whole
family man at some point in life my
everybody in my family is at a Honda
Accord
except my sister used to have a Honda
Civic once used to date a lot of
brothers and that was back in the day
dude back in
if you saw a white girl kind of a thick
white girl with a Honda Civic
they had a brother in the passenger seat
and and that was a different time that
was in the 90s but man thanks for
sporting it bruh you know they had a
pizza guy one time we're at this party
and um what the [ __ ] did that dude do
oh he some guy crashed his car in the
woods it was a pizza guy and I think he
was just an alcoholic but he was also
doing pizza and he crashed his car in
the woods and he um
he came to the party we're having a
party this dude comes up and he's like
bloodied up and [ __ ] he's like I need
help you know it crashed and I was
Domino's and half the people from the
party went to his car and just stole all
the [ __ ] pizzas that make sense
bro you got you can't slip but you got
to bring your [ __ ] items with you
you're gonna [ __ ] pretty that product
up I don't care if you bleed not gonna
care of you dying I'm gonna keep if you
got one foot in a bear trap [ __ ] you
know you got to put them pies in a
[ __ ] sack and do your work man that
guy was really half-assed and now that I
think about it but thanks for calling
Kevin I appreciate it man let's take
another call as to who listens to the
podcast just wanted to know like who you
know who we are homeward my name is
James I live in Nashville Tennessee I am
a doorman at a luxury hotel I dress like
the monopoly man with the top hat and
coat tails and I talk all fancy but in
my part-time I feel percussion
instruments and make music trying to
make that my full-time hmm
I listen to your podcast when I look out
when I cook breakfast and I clean and
when I Drive to work amen brother kind
of a long commute so I appreciate your
content you're funny as hell well thanks
man I appreciate the nice words dude if
I were you ever been a bellman I haven't
haven't I was a busboy at Perkins and I
did a little little hosting you know
it's when they needed it but did you
that male host up yeah dude now male
host a lot of time people think that
fellas are you know what I'm saying at
home
you know homosexual one day I hope to be
a home it's hard to know that but did
you know what I'm saying if you walk
into a place and they got a male host
mm-hmm at the hostess stand
you know I know times are different now
but when I was coming up it was like I
would even if I ever had to do that
because sometimes I worked in Tucson at
this place called City Grill and one of
the guy that made the pies up there got
busted I think for buying a bunch of
illegal shrimp use my own black market
shrimp and saving money you know on the
books or whatever but anyway um this
dude Ted who wrote a bike to work but
anyway uh sometimes if I had to stand in
for the hostess I would just stand real
far away from it and if somebody came in
I would just o just yell and I'm like
hey y'all need a table you know so that
just seemed like I was maybe a waiter in
the distance you know but if you're that
bellman dude here's what I would be
doing when you got rich people's luggage
get a little couple hits of weed in your
lungs blow it through the [ __ ]
luggage right into the bag just send
them [ __ ] home with that [ __ ] let
the dogs deal with it after that get a
lung full of that [ __ ] hemp's better
brother and if I can just blow that [ __ ]
just put your face your mouth or your
lips your pursed lips on the luggage and
breathe it right into the bag get them
stopped at the airport when they leave
yeah get them stop let the rich see what
life is like let the rich see what life
is like dude I remember when I used to
live with my friend beau they had a
closet we put two mattresses in a closet
was a big closet and um and we would and
at night everybody else would party all
night but I had I worked for his dad at
UM shipping your piping services doing
like [ __ ] I don't know what we're doing
really just hiding from the boss all
that right in a warehouse you know to be
honest man but I saw put some blankets
up right there because they didn't have
any doors cuz I had to sleep because I
had to get up about when about 6:00 a.m.
when they went all went to bed from
partying all night
but at right before like they'd all go
to bed they'd all smoked a couple John's
and blow the smoke through the [ __ ]
blankets into my little domicile in
there
so I'm dead asleep dude just it's just
basically inhaling baby right so if I
wake up for work [ __ ] man
and I didn't even smoke weed so I wake
up and just be high as [ __ ] and have to
go to work all day man she was hectic
was this sleeping area at the job at the
warehouse no it was across yelled about
a half-hour away so yeah I would just
get up and and then it would just be
hell because I'd be starving I have to
[ __ ] go to work I'll be high they're
like you're high on the job I'm like I'm
not I mean I am but this secondhand
you know let's pay for the episode here
and I want to say that is there
something that interferes with your
happiness or is preventing you from
achieving your goals
if so better help online counseling is
there for you better help off offers
licensed professionals counselors who
are specialized in issues such as
depression stress anxiety anger grief
self-esteem and more connect with your
professional counselor in a safe and
private online environment anything you
share is confidential and it's so
convenient best of all it's a truly
affordable option and this past weekend
listeners get 10% off your first month
with discount code Theo von no spaces so
why not get started today if you need
help if you are struggling with
something and do not have access to help
you can go to better help calm slash
Theo von th EO vo in simply fill out a
questionnaire to help them assess your
needs and get matched with a counselor
you'll love that's better help calm
slash Theo von th EO vo in and the
reason why I'm advertising for them or
reading this for them is because I've
tried it you know I went on their
services and I you can do Skype you can
do FaceTime on your phone to talk with
the real counselor you know you can text
you I mean you can text in exchange like
that you can just talk verbally
audio-only or you can actually sit there
on FaceTime and speak with
someone and there's some opportunities
you can even meet in person so better
help.com / Theo von if you need help you
know a lot of us need help and sometimes
you know in my life I've just been
afraid to say that I do you know in some
ways I stay you know probably there's a
ton of ways that I still am afraid to
say that I need help and dude I was
thinking the other day I don't even
sometimes I don't even I don't like to
die don't you know it's just something
you don't want to want help it's like
this human thing like it about anything
whether it's a mental issue or anything
it's like sometimes I just don't want to
want help you know I just want to do it
myself and if I can't do it myself I'd
rather not do anything you know but I'm
but I feel like from my own experience
that that doesn't always serve me well
you know in the end you know we can't do
anything alone we couldn't do this
podcast alone I couldn't do it without
Nick and I couldn't do without our
listeners let's take another call as to
who called into um into the podcast and
it's so funny you said Nashville man I I
have this leapers Fork shirt on right
now and I'm thinking about going there
and buying some land man I'm thinking
about you know with some of the money
I'll be making doing some comedy in here
and then I'm thinking about just getting
a piece of land that I could have one
day you know I love that idea I have a
pipe dream I want to have some land in
Wisconsin and live here but be able to
go back there in the summer yeah I love
that yeah land is up
yeah I want to own land yeah that's
whatever yeah I just I don't know man it
just seems like it to be just a you know
just I feel so stressed out out here a
lot of times I'm it's just everywhere
here is like a business I just like it's
always an office you know everything is
just a transaction mm-hmm it just feels
different but thank you for calling and
good luck over there and good luck
making no zom he said he made some What
did he say he made what was it doing I
was into your podcast
when I look out he saw I feel percussion
instruments and make music then
percussion instruments good luck with
that and that's a drum all right let's
take another call here somebody who
listens to the podcast
we ico this is we see I just saw your
research this past weekend and you said
you wanted to know who's listening out
there I'm a 26 year old mom of two am i
listening to your podcast as I feed them
breakfast in the morning
oh wow you think I'm with spoon or with
nipple how are you seeing that meal pass
in it I don't have to get the ages on
those children yeah I'm probably maybe
one of each you know thank you for
listening homework and wanting to say
also that I'm excited to see you on the
29th of March in Phoenix my husband and
I are gonna have a date night and
hopefully cry laughing and gang gang
gang gang maybe you guys can pop that
third that night you know maybe you guys
can get that third child gestation um
but thank you for calling them excited
that you guys are coming out on the 29th
that's there in Phoenix I think we're
gonna add a Thursday night show to
Phoenix as well or maybe a Sunday show
I'm not sure yet
and Kansas City as well I think we're
adding some shows over there this coming
weekend I'll be in San Jose and that is
San Jose that's in California and we're
gonna be doing seven shows maybe eight
shows Thursday through Sunday so that's
gonna be a real ride what else we got
Nick let's hit a little bit of news man
um I'm just keyed up off that [ __ ]
NASCAR brother cars go by so fast and at
first I got there I was like I don't
know if huh middle and then I was like
this is awesome and it wasn't like a rat
it was its way rowdy or like an NFL game
or something it was super calm people
were relaxed and just getting some Sun
um like I don't know if the you know
maybe when the you know when the Sun
sets if that's when like spousal abuse
and everything kind of pops off but it
looks calm at day you know and then it
was a lot of uh yeah just chill people
you know I met one Duty's how you listen
to the podcasts all the time it was just
I'm trying to think over
you know and it started to get the
longer I was a little more exciting at
God they had one wreck and we were
writing the cheap seats we were right
like around the curve so like we're like
if you have a relationship a marriage
you want to be in you sit there and take
your [ __ ] chances you know
or maybe you buy your wife you know you
know somebody Bachelorette you sent a
bachelorette party there and hope your
lady gets popped by a tiresome because
that's the area of that first curve that
was really it was very sparsely seated
but down the way full seats were full
because that's where a [ __ ] you know
a catalytic converter [ __ ] fly over
to over the netting and [ __ ] pop
somebody you know that dead man's curve
oh dude yeah stop naming stuff that yeah
just name it hey here's a curve yeah me
more [ __ ] people would be alive
dude we used to go to this place called
Lando Pines right and it was a waterpark
what was all his named Noah's Ark
yeah Noah's Ark and uh and this was
Lando pines and it was really like a lot
of pedophiles and stuff up there and it
was Turtles had a bunch of snapping
turtles and they had if somebody pooped
on the slide they would shut the thing
out for like basically like for ten
minutes and kind of do nothing and then
[ __ ] start it back up
it was so [ __ ] bizarre like we all
thought they were doing something but
they was kind of I can be standing
around and that's a reverse psychology I
think what are we talking about man you
went to Pine Knoll and Oh Pines yeah and
that was our little waterpark and you
had to drive down this road and it had
like seven dead man's curves on there
I'm like dude just [ __ ] have regular
curves you'll have way more business
we're straight yeah it is kind of crazy
it's like oh we want it to be scenic and
there thousands of people died over the
years yeah so then it's always those
white crosses you feel so bad but at the
NASCAR yeah that one of that curve you
know if you I mean a [ __ ] tire
something could just fly right over that
they got steel netting right there in
front of you but it's not super high
it's only about like 25
and it's curved towards the track but
you could easily see a [ __ ] catalytic
converter a [ __ ] blinker because
those those accidents are strong mm-hmm
you know [ __ ] you know your
ex-husband you know catches a left turn
signal to the face at [ __ ] 200 miles
an hour that shit's gonna [ __ ] sting
let's take it let's hit some news what
do we got Nick sure first up James Gunn
was reinstated as the writer director of
guardians of the galaxy they removed him
last July after oh yeah people made a
big hullabaloo about some of his old
tweets yeah yeah and that seemed um and
it's so now he's back in and a lot of
celebrities came to support him yeah all
the most of the cast of guardians of the
galaxy but they were all like in his
corner yeah and it's kind of create like
Twitter I don't know if you can use
Twitter I don't think Twitter shouldn't
be a news source anymore I feel like and
maybe that's egregious of me to say but
you know somebody says something from 10
years ago what if they were you know a
swim instructor you know and just
because they have that timeline in their
life you can't respect that somebody
went from one place to another place
maybe they had different views and now
their views are dif have changed which
is if if they have it's what you want
like if you have a guy 20 years ago that
was saying racist stuff and then you
have 15 years of him and you don't have
any of that and maybe you have them
doing stuff that's not it is it's just
like it's like we're afraid to even let
people have any proof of their change
you know is that crazy what do you think
no and did you see his his tweets at the
time like I'm always trying to be really
objective on like these stories but his
word just seemed like really bad jokes
like they were crazy they were cringy
and not funny but it really seems not a
fireable offense what he was tweeting
people were saying he was making light
of pedophilia and rape which I guess you
could read it in that week but I think
they were like missed attempted
humor yeah that were really harmless to
be honest yeah and it's like it's like
humors outlawed mm-hmm and it's crazy
and I think at all that's going away so
fast all of that like are you gonna hold
a tweet against me from the past it's
because otherwise it's just what are
those people want like the world to just
be there's gonna be nothing left you
know it's just it's gonna keep going
down until everybody's no good for some
reason which everybody's no good for
some reason anyway we're all not that
good you know two people [ __ ] somewhere
and made one and made us I mean what do
you expect you know I feel like we're
doing the best that we can the guy says
a couple of bad jokes which is every
director has bad jokes and I think this
goes back to what you're saying always
money isn't loyal because like the
second they thought there's a bigger
uproar they thought it would hurt the
movies bottom line they're like you're
out yeah a year later just people aren't
talking about it so like okay you can
come back yeah now now you'll help are
bringing you back will help us yeah yeah
it's crazy that's the truth man once you
you know kind of once you have an
audience or have something that yet
those same people who before we're
writing articles to say one thing now
they'll say hey come advertise with our
magazine and we'll write an article for
you that supports whatever you it's just
you know money isn't loyal man it's
interesting and then also what the [ __ ]
do I know do what other news we got so
James Gunn is back well that's good I
think that's an overall good like we
can't just judge everybody by their
tweets agree
dude I remember I still feel bad about
this sometimes and I don't know why I
don't say this word I don't like saying
this word that much but I remember years
ago on Facebook I was on some mushrooms
and I was at a party or something and I
just thought dude if I was up on saying
you know I'd eat myself right
and for some reason man I thought that
was the funniest thing I've ever heard
in my life so I put it on my facebook
right and this is early Facebook you
know when people were still like getting
jobs on there forgot about it because I
was on mushrooms do die for
everything I forgot I have [ __ ] hands
so dude like the next day I read the
comment I was just like Jesus Christ
like the previous thing had been like
hey I'll be in uh you know in a Fresno
in two weeks at rooster T feathers and
here I was being like somebody was like
doesn't your mom read this like when I'm
old teachers like it was just so
demoralizing but I was also you know 27
years old or you know 30 years old you
know so it's like let's take another
call who's listening to this podcast and
we're grateful for the listeners and uh
and I'll see that other couple over
there in Phoenix make sure to say hey to
me I got a gift for you guys
Oh word Casey oh this is Marissa I'm
from Lincoln Nebraska hey Marissa thank
you for calling from Lincoln America's
that's what is it I want to say they do
snakes but that's Omaha Omaha Steaks
people that eat eat the steaks diners
homeward you wanted people to call in
and let you know where were listening
from so and what we do for our jobs I am
currently a custodian for the public
school here in Lincoln and right now
we're on spring break so just kind of me
all by all by myself in this school but
yeah I listen to your podcast every
every new about the serger is along with
the King and staying with Brendon if I'm
not listening to another made podcast
and listening to either you goon so
anyways stay humble your your frickin
awesome dude I I couldn't get through
this job without what certain with so
many funny [ __ ] so that's a perfect
explanation funny [ __ ] it's so true
or I don't know if that's true but I'm
glad that you think it's true Wow a
female custodian I don't we had one of
those when I was in school did you Nick
mmm-hmm yeah no mister
Leeson I feel like he's the only janitor
for all 18 years of school 13 yeah we
had a mr. Gleason he taught acting and
music but we had a janitor buck our
Jenner has only had one named buck tip
we had got any tip you know I can't
imagine being a female janitor that's
wild I wonder if like Pete I wonder if
like if you get any like sexual
harassment from the students or
something you know because those kids
are so fired up yeah I mean if you know
high schoolers or whatever junior high
you [ __ ] punch them in a bunch of
semen I'll kind of fly out no doubt I
mean they're so just amped up our
hormones you [ __ ] pop somebody in the
neck I'm [ __ ] you know two hormones
will fall on the floor and you mix that
with some Clorox who knows I wonder what
it's like that's interesting I never uh
I've ever been a custodian I wonder I
mean I used to clean up the gym and
stuff I'd used to clean up after school
and I used to like it I like sweeping
because sweeping you get all the dirt
and you get in a little pile and you
[ __ ] go put it somewhere you know I
mean you can put it wherever you want
and then you know you're supposed to put
it in the trash but you can also put it
wherever you want in the whole world so
it's kind of like a little trick I used
to do I had a couple custodial gigs back
in the day I did in middle school I did
my church man the rectory and nothing
happened and then I did in college I did
I had a student services job yeah that
was doing some of the the equestrian
area and some of the greenhouses and
stuff mm-hmm
yeah equestrian worth of the horses yeah
yeah oh wow at the University of
Minnesota they on their st. Paul campus
it's all like animals and agriculture of
school and they have a you clean up
animal [ __ ] or not
I didn't took no I didn't touch the [ __ ]
it was more like that because there's
offices and stuff there's a big horse
area but then there's offices attached
to it so it was pretty regular
janitorial stuff except I saw and smelt
horses
how much poop can be in a horse can you
look that up I wonder how much let me
guess
four
a thousand pound horse will defecate
approximately 4 to 13 times a day ooh
I'm low thousand pound horse will
produce on average 30 sound 37 pounds of
feces daily Wow so so that's like that's
like three and a half bowling balls dude
that's crazy think about that or the
weight of them mm-hmm Wow wonder if you
can fill up like a medium box or like uh
wonder what kind of box that could fill
up 37 pounds is a pretty good amount huh
that's probably at least two or three
book bags full two or three l.l.bean
bags for with that extended cab the big
ones thank you for calling young lady
and thank you for listening to - this
past weekend and I'm glad that you
listened to us and I'm glad that Brendan
and I'm glad they were able to make you
laugh and were able to stay in your ears
while you're looking at all those
squirrely kids running around
speaking of Brendan did you see his IG
story he's at the Miami improv this past
weekend I don't know if it's still up
there but he on Friday and Saturday he
was hooked up to an IV oh wow I don't
even see that
yeah the caption said I think I'm
allergic to Miami so I'll have to get
the scoop from him damn maybe had a
little too much lime you know mm-hmm
that's crazy
yeah I hope he's okay I didn't know that
at all I wonder what could be wrong with
him could this be exhaustion maybe just
the traveling around he could have had a
reaction to something
I was checking on him as soon as we're
done let's take another call here here
we go the hotline as always is nine
eighty five six six four nine five zero
three this episode we're kind of just
focusing on her not really but just kind
of listening to people who listen to the
listening to you cuz you always listen
to me hey Theo what's up it's Ryan from
Arizona was just calling to let you know
that I was in their podcast every Monday
morning while I'm out walking dogs I'm
out here making that dog fit in money oh
yeah yeah I'm walking poodles beagle you
can one of them be Jean oh yeah so thank
you so much do and I'll see you soon
right gang man you are contrato free
Days Around and right now everybody
knows we talked about this the Iditarod
is going on still and if you a [ __ ]
dog down here lounging and you ain't up
in the big race bruh then go [ __ ]
yourself son you know the real pups are
out there running trying to win
something you're out here [ __ ] you
know these dogs he's you know it's just
it's so American you know I'm just gonna
stay down here and not get up there and
get involved in that big hitter so a lot
of the good dogs are up there but thanks
for walking them you know and I think
it's I think it's amazing that anybody
can go in those people's houses during
the day and not steal something that's
what I think is just [ __ ] baffling so
if you can even do that that's amazing
you know much less walk their dog so
thanks for listening man I appreciate
that we got a dog walker we got a female
custodian we got a mama to by spoon in
my nip we got that hotel doorman we got
that Jimmy John's delivery driver boy
let's take one more hey mama what's up
Dakota nice to see you and that's a
hurricane that's our tornado country you
know something you leave a [ __ ]
Rubik's Cube in the yard and the wind
will [ __ ] do it you know it's that
wild area homeward and hos gone into
your question about who's this 28 years
old and then I dig for a pipeline
company so anytime I'm up on the chat so
digging just dirty I Pro you on and you
talked me through the day
I just wanted to say thank you keep
doing what you doing man gang brah thank
you for calling the Dakota and you guys
are the people that in Dateline episodes
always end up finding a body on accident
you ever see that net yeah I love
Dateline yeah oh dude I can't even go to
sleep I feel like without a murder
that's everybody nowadays it's hot
murders hot isn't it crazy it makes you
wonder I don't know okay
people used to talk about like video
games for kids back in the day but all
these women and you watching these
murder shows oh no yeah
yeah I kind of I know this sounds crazy
I wish I was part of like a little
women's group and we met up and [ __ ]
watched it cuz they'd all get scared and
[ __ ] snuggle up on me never like Oh
everything's gonna be fine ladies it's
just the wind
there's a there's a saying I've often
repeated fear is nature's most powerful
aphrodisiac ooh dude that'd be great
actually
you hire a buddy to come in the back
window and just rub a knife against the
wall in the other room just to [ __ ]
get the ladies off like an excited oh
that's just nothing you know you get him
to [ __ ] shoot a gun in the other room
a couple times calm down it's just a cat
it's just the cat we got him some new
symbols
yeah man people love you see if you have
a girl over you got to put on a couple
date lines put on a scary one or put on
that Paula's on or put on that uh Joe
Kenda
dude joke into brother that guy looks
like he could really [ __ ] I don't know
if you've seen this dude or not he's
only I think about five six but at least
four feet of it has to be [ __ ] wiener
I mean that dude that guy's solving
crimes in his sleep I mean he uh yeah
and he always wears a suit and he always
gets the murderer and then they got that
other guy the senior citizen dude you
know and he kind of looks like he's
starting to look like a little bit of
like a decent Liz beyond you know he's
looking like one of those kind of sundry
lesbians you know that you see up in
Idaho he or he's almost he's got
beautiful hair
what's his name can you look him up for
Dateline and Lester Holt first of all
you want to do a mystery Lester Holt who
stole your upper lip brother okay cuz
you only have one lip Lester what about
that we talked about Keith Morrison
Keith Moore as son he's the best he's
always the best he's always like but
what about that shovel it wasn't usually
on the roof
that's my favorite man let's take
another news what do we got Nick
see the recently the largest college
admissions scandal ever was uncovered
over 50 people were indicted of sending
bribes to get their kids admitted to
college and two of the notable names
were Lori Loughlin Aunt Becky from full
house and Felicity Huffman were two of
the names charged Laughlin is the one
really that's grabbed headlines she's
accused of paying bribes up to five
hundred thousand yeah read about this
man it made me at first I was like get
him you know get the you know it's it's
just cheating it's just how it was the
kind of thing that always made me upset
when I was young how like rich like if
you went to like say you in a you know a
group of people got busted by the cops
for something then the rich kids always
got out and you had to stay overnight
you know you didn't have an attorney
your dad didn't know somebody in the
town you didn't get that so then you go
to jail you know it's a lot of times why
a lot of you know you see a lot more
incarceration of blacks and minorities
and poor people overall really poor
people I mean you can see we can always
kind of did you know say it's colors and
this and that and ethnicities but really
it's it's really poverty when you see
poor big because they don't have that
phone call nobody in their family knows
that God to get them out and nobody in
their family knows that guy to get them
into college so it's like you know when
you have some kid who's a fog and you
know you know some kind of kid who's
always had it easy it's like what do you
teach them you know if you pay if they
find out I wonder if she's apologized to
her daughter wonder if they even care if
any of them you know maybe when you're
like rich like that you don't even it's
just part of life you know it made me
mad though cuz I always hated that I
don't know if it's called nepotism or
what it is but it's like where you know
when it's a lot of jobs it's a lot of
like you know your dad knows somebody at
the business and so that's why you got
the job but then some of that it's like
I can't be mad because some of that's
just the way that life works
the thing that just people are bummed
out about is Lori Loughlin daughter
she's one of them is like a successful
youtuber in her own right and this video
came out of her bragging how she didn't
care about school and she was only going
to USC to party and do the game days and
that like really rubbed people the wrong
way cuz like she's clearly squandering
this opportunity that a thousand people
out there would give their left nut for
wow that's crazy man you know when a lot
I mean it's just I don't know yeah it
just makes you mad and I guess it's like
can we be as mad at the kids it's more
the parents really and then part of me
is like the parents they their thinking
is I want the best for my children right
I have the means to do so right so it's
tough but yeah I when you think about
the people who didn't get the
opportunity because it happened that's
where it becomes a problem I think yeah
yeah and then it's like yeah it's just
that it's tough it's a gay you the
parents want the best opportunity but I
think the best opportunity is like
letting the kids learn it would seem
like but you know I think about this
it's like I think about you know if you
grew up with like a you know if not a
lot of means you know when you had to
work hard you had to work early or your
parents didn't have you know the high
education or the opportunities maybe
their parents didn't have them so your
parents didn't really have them and then
but then you kind of you come up in your
life and get to like a different maybe
class hypothetically or a different
financial level then you raise the kids
that were the kids you used to hate
because they had everything that's the
crazy thing to me you know just that's
the thing I start to think about it's
like well if I rate you know if I have
kids one day and they have better means
than I had growing up are they just
gonna be the kids that I judged you know
and was it even right for me to judge
them you know it just seems like just
how do you it's like the middle is
always kind of the best it to be able to
monitor if you can stay in the middle of
things but I don't know man up but it's
yeah that people can't go to school you
know or don't get that opportunity
because some kid who wasn't even yeah I
wonder what her classmates thought like
the if there was any poor kids in her
school in high school were like how does
she get to go how did she get that you
know specifically about lawful daughter
but it's just and sometimes I notice
it's like sometimes it's like one
generation just has to take an elf or
the next one it's like sometimes your
parents had to work their asses off and
then you're the you know so then it
things are easier for the next
generation they're just gonna be the
ones that work hard you know and then
their kids will have it better it's just
kind of the way it goes
a lot of times you know sometimes it's
you know like you know my parents had to
work harder their parents at you know
it's like it takes a couple generations
sometimes for a family to get you know
means to have more of an opportunity and
some of that's just life I think but
damn bro I'd be pissed if I were well
who do you thinks upset about this
probably just who kids that couldn't get
in yeah 100% like overachievers who come
from poor families who didn't get the
opportunity because they don't have
someone in their corner like you said
they don't have that phone call right
yeah man this [ __ ] always made me mad it
just always made me mad when like it's
because also when you're poor it seems
like you judge that you know it's
because it's one of the only things you
have to judge it's like you know you
always feel like those kids have it
easier and in some ways they do maybe
but in some ways they also don't I mean
there's still people with feelings and
you know people that are just living in
the environments that they are living in
like Jordan Peterson says like you don't
necessarily have to have equality of
outcome but you at least want equality
of opportunity yeah so those kids feel
like they're not they're doing
everything they can but it's still not a
level playing field yeah yeah and they
would bring them in they'd be like yes
Suzette here is on the [ __ ] Domino
squad you know and they've like
and that's how they were doing it I
guess they were getting coaches to say
that students played in certain sports
and strange events I think this thing is
going to grow though only this is the
first time you're gonna see this I think
it's this has got to be happening
everywhere and I'm good I think I think
a lot of this stuff is it kind of like
is it does it put big bit of Corrections
out I think needs to have occurred in
America for a long time and everywhere
it's like we're you know it's not just
what you have but who you are
should weigh in on things a little bit
more somehow and maybe that's because
everything kind of always evens out I
think anyway I think you have to believe
that you know karma it's all it always
kind of evens out something's always
seen me easier but then you get into and
you're like oh this isn't really it says
you know it's not easier it's you know
what always it always everything always
seems to even out I feel like but I'm
just rambling we're gonna say no you
mentioned how you believe it's like a
ramp it and I do too like I think this
is happening all the time and then I
don't know if it's like a little Eddie
Bravo in me but I'm like what occurred
to make this one come to light when we
both believe it's probably happening
everywhere but who did some like who
pissed off who to like make this that
all the shit's hitting a fan of a sudden
when I'm sure there's thousands of
people operty operating like this for a
long time yeah yeah well it's like it
when something grows if it gets bigger
than like more people getting involved
more people have an opportunity to see
what's going on could have been somebody
that lost their job and called it out
I'm not sure do you know no I don't I
don't know what like really there's just
there's been a federal investigation
ongoing and they finally just like
announced it but it also reminds me of
like the Bob Kraft thing like there are
thousands of massage parlors where the
happy ending is like a thing yeah and
but this one for some reason makes news
and they're putting other people's names
out there and it's just like why now
right yeah I mean and here's the thing
Bob Kraft 70 something years old
dude you want the guy's wife jerking him
off she's [ __ ] 78 or 90 dude the guy
you want a younger person with decent
flexibility and dexterity to masturbate
the man no arthritis well yeah just yeah
you know
god forbid some of these grandmother's
over there having a jerk him off even if
it's his wife you know if somebody is
they're good at it they [ __ ] you know
juggle or whatever whatever they do
that's the person you want doing it
somebody that [ __ ] can work at a
strip mall and who can get there you
know you you you want this kind of to go
to his wife and have you know she
probably got bracelets on and [ __ ] and
she has to do all of that you know god
forbid I'm not you know I don't think
any woman over 75 is if to jerk a man
off and you know forgive me if I'm wrong
let's take another call here who listens
to the podcast onward hi Co my name is
Amy I'm a big fan I have two kids in
their 20s that also listen to you as
well they're all three of us are very
big fans I just wanted to talk to you
about regular people that's all we are
I work for insurance company my son
works my other son works we're just
regular old people then we listen to you
all the time
and then we talk about what we listen
about and we have a blast with it I also
want to tell you that all three of us
next month will be one year sober all
three of us went sober all at the same
time Wow and we did you know and looking
at you has been a big inspiration wow
that's wild
wow what a neat adventure for you and
your boys to go through to get just to
to be sober and uh see what that is like
and have you know conversations about
that together and see how you feel you
know it's funny I thank you for the call
and thanks for listening and that's I'm
glad that you're able to find common
things to do with your son with both
your sons and just whether it's this or
whatever it is that you're that you have
those things that's really sweet and
that makes me feel good I'm appreciate
you sharing that um I like thinking
about their household before all three
of them got sober
oh yeah a picture and like you and your
brother beating each other up to 80s
rock music oh yeah mayhem
yeah it's putting on some [ __ ] are
all you and your two sons all dressing
up like The Ultimate Warrior beating the
[ __ ] out of each other and having fun
and drinking God dang it sounds fun too
so if you guys do that next year please
send us some videos of that but I'm glad
that you guys enjoyed and I appreciate
y'all listening
let's see Wells listens man let's take
another call here homeward hyphy oh my
name is Shayla I'm just listening to
your limited breadstix podcast that
works me and my boyfriend are from
Bridgeport Connecticut he actually
introduced me to this podcast which I
very much enjoy wow he sounds like a
great guy I'm gonna cow it and we spend
most most of our day listening to you so
we appreciate that appreciate the
entertainment but during our boring or
galleries oh well thank you very much I
find stuff to listen to during my boring
work hours too and sometimes it's calls
from you guys so it's great you know
it's kind of like a it's kind of like
this wild back and forth that we've kind
of created here so my boring work hours
is listening to this back yeah you're
like the full circle yeah everything's
coming full circle but thank you and
your boyfriend for listening I'm not
sure if I'm headed up to Bridgeport I
know that I'm adding some dates for San
Francisco coming up and in where else I
don't even know possibly Toronto
possibly Cleveland but thank you guys
for listening let's take let's go to
another news story Nick I know sometimes
we do things different here and and
today I was just driving back and the
traffic was forever and I was like let's
just do something different and let's
have Nick and we'll just go through it
together
you know gang gang bro some some news
out of your home state of Louisiana
mm-hmm they are reportedly trying to
recoup 26 million dollars in
accidentally distributed tax refunds
last week
a computer error cost 66,000 people to
receive double refund payments they're
trying to get it back yeah well here's
what I'm saying good luck dude you know
if that when that [ __ ] check comes
from the government I'll cast dude it I
will open up a bank I'll build a bank in
my yard and cash that [ __ ] fast anybody
recoup his [ __ ] not in Louisiana you
know somebody [ __ ] bought an extra
canoe with that money you know you know
somebody [ __ ] but you know put down
$200 on the [ __ ] really expensive
oyster you know what I'm saying you know
somebody buggin spent some money on a
fancy remoulade dressing you know a
couple quarts that they just couldn't
get their hands on before you out of
your mind you're getting that money back
man anything else in that story just a
spokespersons urging people to not spend
the money but I think like you said they
should go in there close their bait
withdraw everything close their bank
guys because they said they think
they'll be able to get it back cuz it's
direct deposit so they're just gonna
pull it out yeah good luck that's just
gonna be going go get that money get
that [ __ ] out the government gave you
that [ __ ] boy that's a loan you got the
rest of your life to pay that thing back
go buy yourself a [ __ ] you know a
two-week-old king cake
go get that go buy you go buy your
[ __ ] go buy your ex-husband an extra
[ __ ] uh umm go buy your ex-husband a
damn a Fred McAfee tattoo that he could
get on his back you know go get that
Reynaldo Turnbull chest tattoo you
always wanted go get something real out
there you know you can get something
nice for that kind of money you got that
money
who's that Ohio State receiver that the
Saints have now that's really good Mike
can't Gore might might Thomas yeah go
get that Mike Thomas left full length
leg tattoo that you always wanted go
spend that money on something good go
buy a [ __ ] couple 2000 buckets of
shrimp that's Louise even getting that
[ __ ] back boy
I couldn't do some Callister tattoo you
get that dude bro get that [ __ ] do
some McAllister faced at that's not
blackface is it that's [ __ ] respect
you know get it him you know blue or
purple you know do something sexy you
could do anything it's getting that
money back first of all how in the [ __ ]
does the government accidentally give
away 26 million that's not a government
that's a [ __ ] idiot dude if somebody
I look I've accidentally given away
maybe bunking $20 $60 hundred dollars
not once have I ever accidentally given
away its 1 million dollars you know how
long it even takes you to [ __ ] lose
26 million at least a million times you
could probably only move if you haven't
if they're ones 26 at a time like that
do you don't think on maybe the 650
thousands of time you might gonna have a
different idea and put it back do good
luck getting that [ __ ] Louisiana go
spend your money
everybody getting that money
unbelievable it's going in let you know
where I listen to the podcast
I'm Jimmy I'm a fourth year medical
student and recently I've been studying
for my port examination so all day so
been listening to you in the morning you
kind of start my day off with some good
vibes and then also I think brace to
work out enjoy a listen to the podcast
I'm a recent listener so thanks Jimmy
thanks for the call good luck with that
medical you know good luck being you
could be anything you could be a damn
what Nick be like a gut doctor yeah you
could be a gut doctor come on a podcast
one day yeah and come on our podcast one
day we got dr. Perlman coming on
tomorrow
perlier pearl putter Perlmutter we got
Perlmutter dude and he wrote a book
called grain brain and that's about your
stomach as
so Michael and dude if you don't think
first of all your Perlmutter you know
what I'm saying that used to being a
wiener
but we're very excited to have him in
studio and we got Brian Callens coming
on this week as well and Mark Geragos
couldn't come last week what happened
he's advising he's not actually
representing jussie Smollett but he's
like an advisor on their team and he was
in court they said he had an emergency
fly back east so I think that's what he
did we're rescheduling for later in
April so he's still gonna come in but
yeah he's he's all over the place to
everybody it's all lawyers these days
everything's a lawsuit these days I
wonder if that'll go away at some point
almost get back to the old ways you know
or the old days you gotta ask him ask
him that ask him that very question yeah
but thank you for listening and good
luck with your doctor ship dude all like
doctors dude I had dude two doctors I've
had in my life have been [ __ ]
disbarred
yeah like damn my [ __ ] dies in it two
of them and both times I got called up
about getting involved in something
against I'm a lawsuit against them so
everything is getting sued but good luck
out there man thank you for listening
and um yeah I never thought I thought
about going to law school I think
everybody thinks about that yeah I like
the idea of it too like it's it's logic
wood that's what law school is yeah I
think it'd be valuable for everybody but
yeah I thought about it too yeah and you
don't meet a lot of comedians that were
in law school or have gone to it or
thought about it so I think you know
it's kind of a popular thing where
people are in you know sometimes we'll
get out of one or get into the other you
know I know a couple of comedians that
are lawyers and I don't know a lot of
committees that are also another
profession I mean you know some
part-time professions but like I don't
know there's a lot of full-time
comedians who are also also you know
legal lawyers hey Nick we got an ad here
don't we
what is it Skillshare Skillshare this
past weekend is brought to you by
Skillshare Skillshare it's an online
learning community for creators with
more than 25,000 classes and design
business and more
you'll discover countless ways to fuel
your curiosity creativity and career
take classes in social media marketing
mobile photography creative writing or
even illustration would you draw
whatever I want whether you're looking
to start a new passion start a side
hustle or gain new professional skills
Skillshare is there to help you keep
learning thriving and reaching those new
goals join the millions of students
already learning on Skillshare today
with a special offer just for our
listeners get two months of Skillshare
for free that's right Skillshare is
offering two months - this past weekend
listeners of unlimited access to over
25,000 classes for free to sign up go to
Skillshare comm slash Theo von
again go to Skillshare dot-com slash
Theo von to start your two months now
that Skillshare dot-com slash Theo von
let's listen oh another person that uh
that listens to the podcast thank you
for calling the hotline onward yo CEO
Jason up in Massachusetts what's up
Jason up there mass and I was just out
there homework telling you uh Who I am
where I work when I listen I'm a
manufacturer's rep Burke having it
company and a single father oh I love
cabinets man because a lot of times
you're [ __ ] standing around with
something your apartment you're like
what the [ __ ] do I do with this bro but
our son in a cabinet dude anything you
don't want to see it anymore
fam [ __ ] surprise do me in this
salt shaker playing hide-and-go-seek
you know Indian and the cover remember
that movie loved that movie
it goes back to Little People I was just
thinking Indian the cover yeah next
thing you know they're gonna have some
people get making little people [ __ ]
it you know they're gonna have a
Cherokee you know you know and a little
person little Sandra [ __ ] somewhere
just to make another movie that's
Hollywood brah I wouldn't be surprised
and then they're gonna spend half a mil
to get him in a [ __ ] college over
there at Loyola Marymount
oh we're brother in UEFA and you're a
single father onward listen mom on the
road driving from place to place
got a little six-year-old sweet daughter
girl who listens to listens to Bishop
guns sings along and says gang gang when
something is awesome in her life so
we're raising a ripe my friend all right
be good I like that man
I like this she likes their music thank
you for sharing that that's cool ah yeah
I could see um yeah I don't have any
profanity in their music I think of some
of its it would be great for children to
listen to you know some of the beats are
really they get you going I think
they're like the kind of a southern
Aerosmith in a way but thank you for
listening man we really appreciate it
here let's take a call from another
person that listens to the podcast thank
you so much yo what up boy
it's just boy Mike do you call them my
Jean you wanna know who's listening this
is listening thank you brother
on my way to work in Chicago substitute
teaching
just kind of spread whatever knowledge
that I have to the youth and they're
gonna listen whether or not either way
I'm here at Eastern every day longtime
listener always thought I'd call 180 up
so to get your big mic that substitute
huh dude I remember we had this dude
first of all thanks for your service
brooke has nobody nobody goes to more
[ __ ] than a substitute teacher because
kids were like hey remember the person
that's usually here that we treat like
[ __ ] kids are like now they [ __ ]
sentence some person who's only gonna be
here for one day so we have to treat him
like a whole years worth of [ __ ] at one
time or it went like the substitute is
awesome Afflick it went either way do
you remember t subs you had Nick I just
they were all really short lived like
one and Dunn's I don't know you were
pretty we were pretty ruthless to them
it's it reminds me of Shawshank when the
fresh fish comes in oh yeah wait wait
wait til they cry wait till they cry
yeah the sauce man it was always
sometimes they couldn't hand
dude subs man and here's the thing we
had this one dude he kept he made his
own kombucha mushroom like drink and he
would talk about it every day we'd have
like two gallons of it and he taught a
science because our science teacher got
busted dating a chick at school a
student so be careful they're brought
first of all if a young lady passes you
were a number if I can pass that [ __ ]
back you know what I'm saying brother
don't save it in your phone you're
busted then but yeah man that was
different times dude substitute teacher
I couldn't imagine walking into a class
and thinking from one damnit control
these kids seemed impossible task
yeah Herculean but subs yeah shoutout to
subs how was that not a day we said a
national substitute teacher day people
that just get hit by [ __ ] spitballs
and accused of sex crimes constantly
Jesus Christ thank you for your service
brother and thanks for listening to this
past weekend any other news we got
nicked in the NFL there was some more
movement last week you talked about
Antonio Brown Oh yo del Beckham jr. yeah
Odell Beckham jr. got traded to the
Cleveland Browns do go Cleveland baby
y'all got they got Baker Mayfield's they
got Kareem hunts and they got Odell
Beckham jr. 'he's jesus who's throwing
the ball Baker who's catching it Oh Dale
that's crazy man I miss that they be
Saint Kareem hunt yeah oh wow you got
suspended for eight games but that
second eight anyway you got nicked
robbed in that first day yeah man that's
gonna be good for Cleveland man it's
exciting for them it's exciting for them
good for Cleveland I love that they are
officially the odds-on favorite to win
the NFC East are they were NFC North are
they really yeah Wow the dog pound hell
yeah dude the dog pound was huge when I
was young that Bernie Kosar let's take
one more call from somebody else that
listens Oh weird what is Devon is a
carpenter out of Asheville North
technically as me and since you get your
[ __ ] together in the morning on Monday I
throw that [ __ ] on on the jobsite
and just [ __ ] [ __ ] until
lunchtime usually with the [ __ ]
podcast so again getting dogs a lot of
gang [ __ ] gang [ __ ] bro get that baloney
hitter man that's what I loved about
doing construction or carpentry or
[ __ ] any job was getting to making
that sandwich and getting that [ __ ] at
lunch boy nothing tastes better it dude
even that sandwich is disgusting that
[ __ ] tastes good after you worked for
half a day and you guys work much harder
than I do out there man and thank you
for supporting the podcast and for
listening bro we got this [ __ ] son what
else Nick anything else on the docket
that's all I got for news I said huh
Johnny football speaking of the Browns
he signed with new startup AAF the
Alliance American Football League oh
yeah I saw the guy I saw one of their
games a couple weeks ago San Antonio I
think has a team hmm good luck to him
yeah he's had it look man that's he's
had a lot of second chances you know
you know it's funny I was thinking on
the way here about it's so easy for me
it's so easy for me for me to forget
like all the people that have helped me
in my life like when I start thinking
back I'm like man so many teachers have
helped me so many like friends parents
have helped me you know my own parents
just little thing it's like so many it's
amazing how much help we you know we
probably do get sometimes that we don't
remember or realize you know that just
blows my mind sometimes like I remember
sometimes I would miss the school bus
and they had a man this this kid bubby
and his dad he would give me a ride over
there to school and he [ __ ] blow
cigarette smoke the whole time in the
car and dude I remember I get I get to
fifth grade but I'd be addicted in
nicotine you know I don't have to
practice my spelling words in a cloud of
smoke and it's hard to spell words
sometimes but didn't [ __ ] smoke dude
in a fire basically I mean smoke is just
a fire is [ __ ] cousin and it's hard
to [ __ ] you know you're trying to
spell an inconvenience during a fire man
so I was a pretty good speller because I
went through it you know I mean I went
through really uh you know the buds of
spelling it's like the Navy SEALs
program but but that man died eventually
I don't know what happened to him he had
a dizzy he had something wrong with his
legs when I met him he could barely
drive sometimes I even remember
I'd have to push his knee down to [ __ ]
get the gas for the brake harder so I
guess maybe I helped him to a little bit
on some of those rides but you know I
just think about all the help that I've
gotten man and the help that I get it
you know from listeners of this podcast
you know so many people help and we're
excited we got a single mom for San Jose
this weekend coming up we have a single
mom for four Phoenix the following
weekend we're gonna have to find one for
Australia Australian single mom crikey
crikey what else man so I want to thank
everybody that supports the podcast as
always and uh and yeah I just I hope
this week I can think more about that
you know I just can't do things in my
life alone you know it mean I can be
confident about the things I'm doing but
just you know I called up actually but
when I on the way here I called up they
had a guy named Ken Highland and he
helped produce a podcast in the
beginning you know from my apartment and
he come over there neither one of us
knew what the [ __ ] we were doing I mean
didn't know what the [ __ ] you know and
and I only got his voice mail machine
but it just made me feel so good even
hear his voice you know sometimes things
get going you get going and you just a
lot you don't but sometimes I do you
know sometimes I get going and I just
forget the people that gave me that
nudge in the beginning I think I'd do it
too
yeah we're all guilty yeah and I don't
mean to it's just
so I'm gonna make a point this week to
try and just reach out to some of those
people and just let them know that
they're still with me you know and see
what I can do for them maybe you know I
just I wish there wasn't that muscle
inside of me that that can see the
problems I'll see problems more then
I'll see you know I'll see places that
I'm not that I'm having trouble then
places that I have not had trouble
mm-hmm you know it's like so easy to row
to think about the the things that
aren't going good then to remember all
the moments that weren't and then
somebody helped you or you know I don't
know I don't know what I'm talking about
do you ever know what I'm talking about
yeah i weirdly feel like I'm usually
following your train of thought well
Dane
all aboard man and we're all following
it together man thank you for all the
people that support this podcast some of
them we got the voicemails from here yo
Co this is your boy Greg from Philly you
guys who was called in so uh well I'm
working in Wilmington Delaware even
though I'm living in Philly
okay working in Wilmington Philly's
[ __ ] witness protection program [ __ ]
right there but hey we got people in the
WPP listening and one more because yo
what's up dawg oh yes I'm listenin bro I
wanted to let you know my name is Shane
um that's under fake when he said that
did Shane are you reading that off of a
card I work for a company it's a legal
cannabis grow out in Denver Colorado and
there you go boy so damn right you
[ __ ] using that fake name boy legal
cannabis Shane out there Sean I mean
Shane yeah I'm he's Sherlock at that
high altitude Shane all listeners man
thank you guys and you know we did it
man we are making this thing a real
thing and we do it together and uh and I
hope that we can find many more ways to
give back to to the people that make
this podcast a reality which is all of
us you know to the listeners and I think
we'll be able to Nick I think as some we
can brainstorm more and just try to find
other ways to do it you know whether
it's helping somebody start a pot you
know I don't know what we can do but I
know we do some stuff but I think we can
do more stuff you know
I just don't know what it is man but I'm
sure we'll have some ideas but thank you
guys so much man and I mean that and and
we'll just go out like we came in dude
let's celebrate living man we're here
together we did it
[Music]
thanks man you're welcome
do you remember we use this long enough
yeah
180 episode that's crazy 182
really this is 182 I always thought this
part of the song was weird you know this
room we're gonna die yeah it's very
morbid it is kind of sorry about this
sorry about the song guy
[Music]
thanks for let me get through this
episode man oh yeah
[Music]
a little bit of beetles in it they're a
little huh right there that part or
maybe not I don't [ __ ] know anything
about music
[Music]
happy st. Patty's happy vernal equinox
March 20th man so we want all things
equal like we said before that's what
I'm saying man
feel your butthole get a little wet on
the vernal equinox boy like your booties
been drinking out of one of those wide
mouth water bottles dude that's what it
feels like your butt will get a little
bit wet if you notice that you know
you're more you will sweat more during
the equinox then at any other two days
of the year and that's a true story can
check that out you guys be good to
yourselves man because I know you
deserve it and I'm gonna try to be good
to myself this week as well thank you
very much
you